Steve welcome back what is it we're
going to talk about today then well I
thought we'd have a chat about ebooks I
mean I dusted off my Kindle the other
day and I've been using that to read
various things so I thought it'd be a
it's about time we had a good chat about
how ebooks work and the form I study
gives them Brady and I did a video where
we looked at the text formatting
involved in making something look nice
on an e-book we read it I think you
briefly into this oh absolutely but what
we haven't talked about is how do you
actually represent an e-book how do you
create the file format that's going to
need can you just use something like PDF
or HTML which has been used before or do
you need to create some sort of new file
so I thought what we do today spend a
few minutes just having a look at how
ebooks work so extremely recently we
made a video with Professor Alton Kirk
who talked about using some software to
convert a published format into an eBook
format we now have an electronic ebook
version of it is this the same kind of
thing we're talking about today yes I
mean that software is going to produce
an epub file for certain eBook readers
and a dot mobi file if it's going to
something like a Kindle so that's the
sort of end result what I want to talk
about is actually how does that file and
particularly how does epub actually
represent the book I mean you might
think this is straightforward I mean
we've been printing documents pretty
much since computers came along Dave's
covered things like PostScript in PDF
and tear off before that which have been
around since the 60s 70s and 80s in
development why would be books be any
different and then the easiest thing to
understand is if you think about how a
books produced so when a books produced
the writer comes up with whatever they
want to write and they will then go and
write it either by hand on a typewriter
hopefully into a word processor and they
will send the publisher that file to
then go and create the file so they will
send the publisher I say a word document
and the publisher will see the
manuscript from the author when whatever
format they've used and they will send
that traditionally to an editor to sort
of check with it actually is spelled
correctly that it does what it says on
the tin and make any changes then went
third editor and the author are happy
with it they will send it to a
typesetter it will take the document
lay it on me
to fit on the pages are going to make up
the book and then they can send that to
the printers to print the books and it
can be shipped to the shops or whatever
to be distributed for us to read and
that's generally straightforward because
all the books are the same size the text
is the same size in them you might have
a few variations and you might have a
large print copy produced you may have
paperback and hardback but you probably
have two or three different variants of
it that will be produced so you can
easily typeset it but use a nicely
looking layout and then send it off what
will often happen these days is that
what would we receive from the time
setter to the publisher to be sent to
the printer is a PDF and you might think
well that's great we can display PDFs on
our Kindle on our iPads why do we need
to do anything else well the problem is
that as we said that PDF has been
created for a certain page size a
certain book size and we can view that
on our device but I had advice this size
is likely to be different to that page
size I once spent a few minutes drawing
out all the different devices screen
sizes I use to view documents
electronically and it was a vast
different amount of sizes so if we just
use PDF great as it is and it displays
the document brilliantly then we would
either have to scale it down so the
checks will become very very small or
we'd have to sort of scan across it
scrolling between it anyone who used PDF
in the late 90s early 2000s remember
having to read documents online where
you end up having to pan across the page
to read it all and in the end you just
printed it out and read it off piece of
a4 paper because it was too much trouble
fortunately we've got high resolutions
and bigger monitors so that problems
gone away to an extent but in the e-book
realm we have that same problem the
Kindle has a screen size is about that
big the iPad is bigger than that so one
of the things they wanted with the
format's that represent ebooks is that
they want a format that can be displayed
on any size screen still just have
contained the book but we can load it on
this size screen and it displays to this
side or we can load it onto an iPad or
an iPhone an Android phone whatever
device you want to view it on even
display on your TV if that's what you
wanted to do and we
here at the right size so we can just
take PDF you might think well what about
HTML HTML will rescale can resize our
web browser to be whatever size we want
but hTML doesn't have a concept of pages
and with ebooks or trying to sort of
steal things that we're turning the
pages of reading the document in a
similar fashion we don't want a long
scroll of the complete document so what
they did was that they created new
formats to describe a book specifically
for display on an e-book reader
specifically as electronic books and
these contain the document but they
contain it
not white PDF or PostScript between its
fixed final form but in a form that can
be resized to fit whatever display
you're using and in addition if you
wanted to to include some interactivity
to have audio in there or video clips
and so on to create the format so it's
designed to be able to re reflow to
resize to fit what every device you want
and this is great because it means if
you perhaps got a worsening eyesight you
can increase the size of the text to
make it easier to read and so on so you
can personalize how it looks for your
own reading preferences so Steve who's
the day in this situation it depends I
mean you're on the Kindle the they would
be Amazon who bought mobipocket I think
it was many years ago who developed the
format that represents them for everyone
else these are format called epub which
is developed by a consortium of people
who do that any contains people from
Adobe and other companies that are
interested in this a bit like with HTML
and the w3c group bit like with PDF and
the ISO standard is various people so
they is a pretty good capsule to refer
to the people who are involved in
creating these eBook standards I think
is there's a lot of people from various
companies is there a sort of special
sauce here there's some people like you
know guarding their way of doing it or
is it fairly open and fairly you know
tried and trusted techniques for this
yes I mean the epubs very open you can
go and download the specifications you
can read through them they're just like
the right there on the w3 website as
well just like the HTML stands and so on
so that's developed fairly open Amazon's
is Amazon's format I think it is
described but it's not it's developed
for what I was in need I think is
probably the best way of putting it so I
think a good
place to start is to actually just take
an electronic book in this case I've got
one called beautiful code which is a
collection of essays by various people
including Brian Kearney who news
appeared on computer file describing
bits of code that they found really
really interesting to look at as
published by O'Reilly it's been around
for ages but I happen to have both the
physical copy in the office which I
can't get to at the moment but also the
electronic book format on my laptop and
I thought it would be quite good just to
actually have a look at the file and
we'll open up the file and just see how
it's created and we'll see things that
we're almost certainly familiar with in
there the first thing to say is that
this even though it says is epub is
actually just a zip file it's just a
standard zip file like any other zip
file and we can extract that so if I
just use the command line I've created a
folder and I unzip that epub file will
see that it extracts a whole load of
files that represent that book and if we
look at the things that we've got here
we'll see there's some dot PNG files
which is in images will see some dot
HTML files that represent the text so I
said before you couldn't just use HTML
and you wouldn't want to use it on its
own input epub just use HTML to
represent the pages it's just standard
XHTML to represent the pages but there's
other files alongside that to create the
format so just like a Word document or
an Excel document these days and lots of
other formats an ePub file
electronically just a zip file that
contains all the things needed to make
up that book so what have we got well
we've got some various files for the
open container format which are
necessary and these are the same if it's
an ePub file or a Word document
but the real interesting stuff is inside
this folder here there's a file in here
we can see all the HTML files and so on
that represent the different chapters so
if I open up this chapter we can see
there's a pretty plain looking HTML file
this is the one I was saying by Brian
Kernighan it's about writing a regular
expression match your days been talking
about regular expressions a lot there's
lots of stuff there so that's a standard
file what makes this an e-book and
rather than just a standard file is it
if we scroll down we'll find that
there's another file title open in a
second
it's lots of chapters in this book and
they've all been split up into sections
and we've got some fonts here as well
but there's this file here Khan
OPF and this is the file that defines
how the book is gonna work is so like
this of backbone of the e-book let me
just open this into a text editor this
is the the packaging format is perhaps
the best way to describe it use EEPROM
this as we can see is a version to ePub
file there's also epub three is the more
modern standard but a lot of the books
still seem to be using epub to copy the
compatibility reason and if you don't
need the extra features offered by epub
three it probably works pretty well just
using epub two so yeah epub three
readers will be able to open an ePub 2
file and so on so what do we get in this
document well the first section inside
the package is the metadata and if we
open that up what we'll see is it just
describes the book so includes things
like the ISBN there and this is using a
previously existing format it's RDF is
using what's called dublin core to store
the metadata it's an XML representation
and this is just a standard way of
representing this data so there's
nothing nothing new has been created
here a lot of the ePub stuff is taking
existing technologies and packaging them
together to create this eBook format the
cleverness is in the software and the
way it's then displayed to the use of
the format's relatively straightforward
and huger up the specs online so we say
what the title of the book is in this
case it's beautiful code the copyright
information who's contributed into it
and so on and etc so that sections
straightforward and that can then be
displayed perhaps on the title page of
the book and so on the next section is
what's called the manifest and what this
does is it describes every single let's
call it an asset that's used inside the
ePub now if you think about if we were
doing this as a on the web we would just
put the files on the server and the
server could then serve them but epub
has been designed to be a self-contained
file that can be pushed for the most
cases onto a device and that device can
then read the book without ever having
to talk to the internet and it may not
even have a network connection there's
some exceptions in epub 3 for audio and
video to be stored externally on the web
but in general the ePub expects all the
files needed to be displaying it to
exist within the package that it's being
used that
and what happens here is we're defining
all those files and so we've got a
reference to the actual file within the
package within the conductor in this
case so top ncx
is the first one we can see the same for
the different files that make up the
document the HTML files and it defines
what they are it gives them an ID so
that can be referred to elsewhere within
this file and it also specifies what
their mime type is so that the software
knows how to understand it
what does mime son for just yes it's the
multi-purpose internet mail extensions
but one of the things it defines is a
way of identifying each type of file in
a way that's unique and this is just so
knows what formats will expect them when
it's opening them we can then use the
right bit to go and get them out in the
zip and open that file the other bit we
have and this is the most interesting
and this is the bit that sort of tries
in if you think about a physical book is
the section called the spine and what
this does is it takes all the files all
the files that contain the the content
of the document not the images and
things which should then be referenced
by those files and it ties them into a
specific order that you would appear as
you read through the book so you'd start
off perhaps with chapter 1 and then it
would say says chapter 1 and that's
followed by chapter 2 and so on and all
the files that make up that order
so if we look at the spine we will see
that the first thing we've got is a
reference to the cover so we've got a
reference to the item which is called
cover and if we look in the manifest we
will find that there is one of these
cord cover which refers to cover dot
HTML and then if we look at that file
you'd see that that represents the cover
of the book and then we have a whole
series of other ID references and in
this case they are not humanly readable
you could generate them automatically as
is the case here or you could put
chapter 1 chapter 2 whatever you wanted
to do but each of these will appear in
the manifest to refer to the file and
when you open the e-book on your ebook
reader it will open the first one and as
you scroll through the pages it will lay
them out page after page after page then
when you get to the end of whatever file
it is it'll go on to the next file and
lay them out page after page after the
page so you can swipe through the
different chapters
or whatever makes up this book so think
about this is this is defined how you
read through the books and the default
thing it doesn't define how you would
navigate through the book so what we
also get right at the top of the spine
and this is something where a pub -
which is the fire we've got here differs
from equal three which is what came
later you'll see the on the actual
spying element in the XML we have a
reference to the table of contents which
is the file ncx TOC if we look in the
manifest we'll see that's the first one
that that's a file is called taco ncx
and it has a line type of application /x
dt b NC x + xml what's going on here
well this is actually using an earlier
standard which is called Daisy which was
developed for producing audio books so
it's a it's a file the format for
creating audio books but it also
contained a way of describing the table
of contexts in there in a sort of XML
format and if we have a look at that
file I'll see this is another XML file
that defines the table of contents so
it's say the book's title is beautiful
code and then we have a navigation map
that says we have a navigation point
which is this one which is the first
thing has a type of beautiful code then
content another navigation point and so
on and this defines a table of contents
which the software could then render for
it this is one of the things that
changed in epub 3 is that they actually
sort of using the Daisy format that said
know what we'll do is we'll store the
navigation document using XHTML using
some of the new tags nation well 5 in
this case the nav tag so you just define
it as an XHTML document using a very
precise subset of XHTML that should be
said in this case that can then be
loaded in by the ePub reader to do the
same sort of thing and you tag it in the
manifest as being the navigation file
with the properties tag on that but the
actual layout of the document is just
standard XHTML as we saw so if I find
chapter 1 again we can bring that up and
it's just standard text you can use a
lot of the features of HTML or XHTML
when you're laying these things out but
certain aspects
ss aren't necessarily supported by all
eBook readers and so on so you might
probably want to look at the specs to
make sure you choose the right ones that
you use but you can get some pretty good
lay out of it as we can see here epub 3
extended this allowing things for
animations you can use SVG in there
instead of HTML if you were to get a
more fixed layout in certain sections
and you can sort of sequence things so
that some audio can play when you click
get to part of the text or video stars
starts at the same time and so on way
before I had any kind of e-book reader I
remember reading a story about 1984 Big
Brother ironically being or maybe it
wasn't ironic being removed from
people's eBook readers I think it was
Kindle at a time but I'm not sure it's a
vague memory of of thinking wow well
that's the ultimate Big Brother you know
you're trying to read a book and then
somebody takes it away from you why and
how does that happen yeah I mean I
remember the exact story was 1984 on the
Kindle I think although perhaps
Fahrenheit 451 would be a more
appropriate book for it to have happened
whether we like it or not and I think
it's right people who write books write
it to support their families they would
expect to be remunerate it from it and
so the book formats do have support
built into them to support digital
rights management so that you can buy a
copy of a book but it's limited to you
so I can buy a book and read it but if I
send this file to you you would not be
able to open it and the way that works
is very straightforward within the file
the actual contents the assets the HTML
files the image files and so on they're
encrypted using standard encryption
technology and inside the e-book package
the person who's selling it to you so
this is Apple with their system on
iBooks or Adobe with their bookstore can
use their digital rights management to
make sure you've got the key so that you
can decrypt it but I can't then send it
to someone else so that they can decrypt
it and so on so do they do they alter
the file for each book then is it as
each book different or is it that
they're literally giving you the keys
with the book good question I haven't
delved into it in a detail but I mean
there's two ways you could do it you
could encrypt the files using a
key and then encrypt those keys within
the file so that only you can decrypt
the key to decrypt it or you can encrypt
it specifically for the user if you
think about the way these are being
distributed they're being sent from a
server to you so it'd be very easy for
the server to just go through and
encrypt each of these files and create
the encrypted file on the fly as it just
that so I imagine that that's what's
happened certainly that's what happens
with things like Apple's iTunes Store
when they were selling music that was
encrypted back in the early 2000s they
encrypted it on the fly specifically for
you or me or whoever's listening
if these Eve publishing formats have got
all these kind of flexible options and
possibilities
will they overtake and replace things
like PDF so that's a good question will
you replace the web will you replace PDF
interesting question I mean it's been 10
years now that these have been on the
the field I mean I think I bought my
first e-book reader in 2009 2010 if not
earlier eBook sales have shot up
stagnated perhaps dropped a bit maybe
coronavirus will mean people prefer to
buy e-books electronically rather than
venture into a bookstore to buy a
physical book covered in viruses
interesting we're now talking about the
computer version being safe from viruses
and the physical one being but I digress
yeah but it hasn't yet there's also did
they do different things so the
advantage of PDF you know what the
author wrote and saw when they wrote it
is what I'm seeing now you've got that
canonical representation that we've both
seen you don't get that with epub and
there are some cases where that is
absolutely important you can see it in
the legal profession you can never
replace PDF there with ePub because it
just would not be acceptable and even
perhaps we're sort of the scientific and
academic community things people do want
to change things away from PDF but there
is something to know that the document
you're reading is what the author wrote
and you know that if that equation looks
like that that's what the author
intended you to look like even if it's
wrong rather than that that's how the
software has interpreted it too so I'm I
still think this this space for both
formats and I think they both have their
advantages and interestingly you are
able to drop a PDF into an ePub
document to use it as an opportunity
representation and you can reflow PDFs
to certain extent but that's a story for
another time right early on you
mentioned you could even put it on your
TV I remember being so into a book at
one point I was reading it on my phone
and I had a chromecast in an Android
phone and I went to eat my lunch and I I
casted their book onto the TV which we
have on the wall in the kitchen so I
could eat my lunch still reading